hi my name is Rob Grado I'm the head of
ILM Industrial Light and Magic and most
recently I was the visual effects
supervisor for solo a Star Wars story
we're going to take a look at the Kessel
run and how we achieve some of those
visual effects
[Music]
so when we were first thinking about how
we wanted to shoot all this material
inside of the Millennium Falcon cockpit
we realized we were gonna be spending
more minutes with han and chewie and the
cast inside the cockpit of the Falcon on
this movie than on any of the Star Wars
up to this date so we knew we wanted to
do everything we could to kind of
elevate the level of the experience so
that's when we came up with this idea to
try to do as much in camera as possible
meaning we wanted the real cameras to be
in the real location and to look out at
in this case a screen that would have
the real footage on it so that footage
would light the actors and light the
cockpit but also could be just
photographed directly so those shots
that we get over the shoulder of Han
Solo when he's piloting the Millennium
Falcon those shots could be in-camera in
many cases so this tube that we're
flying through here is the safe way to
get to Kessel and that's the way of
course Han is going to take the team out
how about that is that real trouble the
first thing they do is run into this
Star Destroyer blockade so moments like
these are actually moments that we had
prepared on the wraparound projection
screen wall so when the actors were in
the cockpit they actually saw something
that was either exactly what you're
seeing here or something was very close
and representative to what you're seeing
as the sequence plays along on top of
that we layered interactive elements
whether it was blaster fire coming from
the TIE fighters or later in the
sequence we build up to lightning and
different kinds of strikes those we
could trigger all interactively you
can't make the Kessel run in less than
20 plus six watch me
yeah it was really fun to actually
revisit that parsecs quote and make sure
that the story we told correctly
explained it you know it's such a
throwaway line in the original film it's
the ship that made the Kessel run in
less than 12 parsecs I remember talking
with John Kasdan who was the writer one
of the two writers John and Larry Kasdan
wrote the the movie and John was
obsessed about making sure we did a good
job honoring the history and honoring
what we all love about those original
references and paying those off and also
providing a plausible explanation which
is which is really one of the fun things
we got to do in this film
the shot where the Millennium Falcon
banks hard to its left and pulls a
90-degree turn into the sidewall was
when we discovered again after a bit of
exploration trying to make a really
clear signal to the audience that he was
taking a shortcut he was gonna go the
wrong way tying that to a strong visual
that says we're going off course those
were actually carbon Berg's so they're
made of carbon which of course is
something that later is gonna revisit
Han later in his life when he's actually
frozen in carbonite some of the same
ingredients go into these rocks which
you might not know just from casually
watching that gunner station of course
we've seen in multiple movies but Ron
Howard had this idea that he wanted this
to feel as much like a car chase as
possible like those classic 1970s car
mount angles so we set up a camera just
outside of that gunner position and then
the artists at ILM put that exterior the
Falcon the glass the gun all about
acting in front of woody so his visual
effects supervisor I'm responsible for
all of the stuff we can't achieve on set
and then I get to work with really good
people so dumb to eat special effects
Department rigged this phenomenal rig
around the cockpit of the Millennium
Falcon my job on set was to make sure
that all the pieces were coming together
and dum tui and his team were standing
by on the rig making sure everybody was
safe but also making sure the ride was
big enough to really be convincing on
camera one detail that you know we were
studying was in the old movies when they
went into hyperspace they push the lever
and it was a pretty smooth process into
hyperspace and it was Ron Howard you
said well wouldn't it be more fun if we
add some extra bump and a little bit of
extra life to it them so you'll see that
this movie has quite a bit of cockpit
activity and most of that's real
hydraulic motion in the cockpit every
once in a while for speed we do we would
call it start wrecking and everyone
would fake one but most of the time
where you're seeing there is actually
real physical movement in the cockpit
so there's a bit of a story about the
Falcons landing gear as you can see in
that shot where the gear comes down
there's actually five landing gear on
the Millennium Falcon in this shot which
matches the landing gear that you see in
Empire Strikes Back and Return of the
Jedi but it doesn't match the original
Millennium Falcon built for episode 14
of the original Star Wars in that film
they only had three landing gear so we
thought maybe there would be a way to do
some continuity ninjitsu and this move
here so if you watch the sequence really
carefully you'll notice that Han
actually breaks off the front two
landing gear so that leaves us at the
end of this movie with a falcon that has
been ripped to shreds from the Falcon we
see at the beginning of the film and is
missing its first two landing gear so it
sets us up perfectly for Episode four
and then in the time between Episode
four and Episode five you notice when we
pick up the Falcon and Chewie in Episode
five and Empire Strikes Back
Chuy's been working on repairs to the
Falcon this entire time so we've just
imagined that he finally got some
replacement landing gear for those front
two and that's how you know went from
three landing gear to five but of course
we started with five in this film so Han
and Chewie worked together he comes down
on that carbon berg slides there and
actually kicks up enough carbon to
freeze that TIE fighter so you can
actually say II took out that last type
fighter by freezing it in carbonite
which is something you might not have
noticed on the first viewing if you
didn't know that was carbon that Co
actions getting real right okay so that
symbol that you see there there's a
whole story behind El trees navicomputer
and the way it actually becomes part of
the Falcons navigation system here has
kira assembles it and puts it in the
back of the Falcon now but if you look
at the design of the messages on that
screen that actually corresponds to the
design of the Falcon cockpit for the
rest of the series so the idea there was
to just kind of make that reference and
try to tell the story that this is how
the Falcon got such a good job of
computer
I don't know where your ship doesn't
communicate but it has a mystic you
the idea here is we've left some of the
most chaotic part of the storm but we're
coming across this giant creature who
was named suma who you shouldn't fly
near if you know where you're going but
of course we don't because the
navicomputer just getting booted up
right here so we're on Herod thought it
would be really fun to do this scare
moment and this is one of those times
we're having those wraparound screens on
set really paid off because not only
were the actors getting immersed in the
right lighting you know as they light up
the headlight of the Millennium Falcon
and see that eyeball but they all got to
react to the eyeball so the reaction we
actually got from the cast in that
moment when the eyeball open was it was
pretty authentic so seumas design was
really inspired by the deep-sea fish and
we referenced a ton of different ones
but especially the eye was one
particularly gross deep-sea fish that
had this giant eye with a super
reflective retina and we thought that
would be really cool for a creature that
was going to be hundreds of times a
scale of the Millennium Falcon and found
somewhere way out in deep space and had
to survive off of we're guessing it had
to survive off of the energy that was
given off by the storm so somehow it
would must collect this energy and maybe
it was attracted to the energy in the
Millennium Falcon James Klein again led
the team that designed Summa and there
were some early designs that came in
from the production design team as well
so there were lots of starting points
but when Ron Howard saw several
different designs he saw one head that
he really liked and he really liked the
way the tentacles draped and another one
we were able to put those together to
create the final creature the whole idea
of the way we shot asuma's experience
here in the Kessel run was to keep the
creature hidden as much as possible I've
worked on movies like Independence Day
where the camera is very formal and kind
of third-person and then I've worked on
movies or I really loved watching movies
like jaws and those kind of things where
you barely get to see the bad guy and
it's slowly revealed over the course of
the film and we wanted seumas brief
story in the film to more reflect a jaws
like moment where it takes a while
before you see the scope of the whole
creature and
in fact you really don't even see the
size of the creature end to end until
that one master shot where assume is
getting sucked into the vortex that's
the moment this gravity well was a real
design challenge right because it's got
this high concept that it sucks
everything in and you've got to make
that really clear visually so you want
to tell that story as clearly as
possible earlier in the development of
the film we had the idea that maybe
there would be multiple gravity wells
and Han would figure out his way through
the rest of the Kessel run was actually
to navigate at the point at which these
two gravity wells got really close he
was gonna go between them and shoot out
there really fast we tried a bunch of
different designs but we could just
never get that to read visually clear
enough and when we simplified it down to
1 gravity well that's when the sequence
really started to work so what we're
showing here with Summa is just how
dangerous this MA is and how much
trouble the Falcon is in if they can't
figure out a way to get out of here and
in fact when we destroy him Summa this
was an idea that came out pretty late in
the production and we were talking about
how soon his head was gonna go into the
maw and we were kind of debating how
fast it should move because it's so big
and all these things and somebody I
think James climb again pitched like
what if we actually ripped off his skin
and then saw the skull crush inside
there and it's not a very long shot does
actually split over a couple of shots in
the final cut of the film but if you
look carefully you actually watch that
skull get crushed by the gravitational
force of this MA
so the idea of those views out the
cockpit is that Han has seen a tiny
window that l3 has pointed out on the
navicomputer and he's trying to pilot
the the ship using the timing of that co
axiom thrust down that narrow channel
and that's what he does here to try to
get the Falcon out of course we have
just interior engine shot where we get
to actually do the kind of what we
called the Pennzoil shot or that
gratuitous inside the engine shot and
then the Falcon doesn't cooperate just
like it always doesn't cooperate but
they get it working just in time to be
able to do this giant acceleration so we
love as a visual effects team thinking
about those books that are later gonna
draw out how the Falcon actually works
in fact we used some of the old books
which are written like car manuals just
talk about how the Millennium Falcon
actually works and then we have people
on the team and Lucasfilm Pablo Hidalgo
is one of the one of the people who's a
great collaborator who is willing to
kind of work with us on the
pseudoscience of where everything is
laid out and where we're gonna cheat
where we're gonna keep things real and
we did base it on some of the components
of a real car engine at least loosely
and then James Kline and the art
department team actually built 3d models
of it to test it out and 3d printed them
to make sure we liked the way the the
the engine was kind of laid out so I
think as much thought went into that
that one shot which only takes what is
that five seconds in the final film as
much thought about design and especially
engine design went into that biz as any
of the shots in the movie
[Music]
so the idea in this last section of the
sequence of course is that two giant
carbon Berg's that were trying to go
between they're closing in we have very
little time left and the co axiom is
about to go too so there's multiple
ticking clocks and then Honda's reap
rising that moment earlier in the movie
where they didn't successfully escape on
that speeder but now that he's got the
Falcon and the right team he can
actually pull it off just in time so
hopefully it's a great climactic ending
and pays off the beginning of the film
as well there's nothing more fun than
getting to work with incredibly talented
actors like Alden and like Donald Glover
who plays Lando in this film and one of
the most fun moments for me on this show
was when we were sitting around in the
very first day that we had to cast
inside the cockpit of the Millennium
Falcon and they were in this wraparound
screen and when we first sent him up
there I just had the media set to a
quiet star field and at the end of the
sequence we were playing Lando and l3
reach over to the hyperspace levers and
push them forward and they go into
hyperspace and without warning the cast
in advance we had set up the Millenium
Falcon cockpit to shake and I had the
hyperspace media on cue so when they put
themselves in hyperspace they would just
go into hyperspace and the funniest
thing was once they stopped kind of
laughing and screaming at each other
when they from from being immersed in
hyperspace
I heard Donald Glover he'd kind of like
he was sitting in the pilot's seat and
he kind of leaned back and he put his
head down for a second even he goes I
had the headphones on so I could hear
I'm talking into his mic he said this is
the coolest thing I have ever done to
hear him say that I was like I gave
Donald Glover a cool moment in the
cockpit of the Millennium Falcon so that
was pretty awesome
the very first version of the script had
a bunch of beats laid out but those
beats continued to evolve over the
course of the the film so the things
that were really clear in the script
from the very first version were that
the Kessel run was going to be a
shortcut across the most dangerous way
to get out of Kessel which sort of
resolves the whole parsecs distance
thing so we know we're actually taking a
physical shortcut in addition to taking
us on a really
path the ideas evolved with us and the
director Ron Howard really organically
over the entire production of the film
how much of Kessel run was based on the
original legends material it really
wasn't at least from a visual effects
and design perspective it wasn't heavily
referenced at all we referenced Jules
Verne we referenced like these
spectacular crazy worlds but we weren't
really looking specifically at some of
that old reference material on this film
we actually shot over a long period of
time both with Chris and Phil directing
and with Ron Howard directing although I
think the way it worked out actually was
the material that you see in the film
was mostly photographed by Ron Howard
just the way the timing ended up working
out we actually hadn't shot a lot of
Millennium Falcon cockpit that I recall
while Chris and Phil we're still
directing the film so I'm Rob braid oh
thanks so much for taking this journey
with us through the Kessel run
[Music]